wenn du ansprichst die rot-blauen mein
name ist khan herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde gar bestehe ich bin dieses
kleine mädchen hier muss hier
durchlaufen und kann was mache ich kann
hier die tür aufmachen um raus zu
schauen und zu sehen dass ich ich habe
nachbarn in unserem garten liegen
tatsächlich sehr viele waffen rum und
ich kann ist sie ganz normaler vorgarten
eigentlich ich nehme einfach mal die axt
und sogar meinen garten zerstören
wie geil dieses spiel eigentlich handelt
es in diesem spiel davon dass ich
irgendwie müll raus bringen muss ich
habe gerade das auto des nachbarn
geklaut und fahren hier die ganze
vorgärten kaputt kann ich theoretisch
andere menschen von lissabon kioyo ich
kann auch bäume zu erfahren
wieso kann ich da nicht rein
falls euch die musik nervt ich hab's
tausend mal probiert die irgendwie
auszustellen aber ist dies nicht
glücklich nichts erfahre gerade einfach
die komplette nachbarschaft und töte
menschen und zerstöre beule und träume
und gemüse und gab es ja alles gemacht
hast mir wurde auch vor zwei minuten
gesagt die polizei jetzt töten wird
allerdings gibt es hier glaube ich gar
keine polizei so wichtig weil sonst wäre
schon welche gekommen ich glaube die
musik ist aus freunde
wir können alles machen und wir keine
musik mehr ok nach wahl hat dass irgend
jemand gesehen dass hier vorne sie
zuerst sollte man dann tatsächlich nicht
kaputt machen
denn es ich bin tot nein die musiker an
auch wenn die musik einen noch so sehr
aufregen kann wir haben eine slow motion
funktion
eigentlich nichts besonderes ich laufe
hier ungelogen schon seit sechs minuten
robben und versuche das irgendwie die
musik aufhört aber wie lange habt ihr
denn vorhin darauf gewartet wo bin ich
denn hier gelandet ich bin in
irgendeinem raum war
jetzt können wir uns wieder den
alltäglichen aufgaben eines vorstadt
bewohners widmen alter grafik von dem
spiel finde ich aber ehrlich gesagt
richtig nice allein wie die darauf
taubenhaus stellt da wir ein
vorbildlicher nachbar sind werden uns
natürlich mit den nachbarn unterhalten
über die probleme bla bla bla bla bla
anscheinend ist der stein attraktiver
als ich schaut her wir haben die melone
ich versuche jetzt wirklich im spiel zu
schaffen und zwar eine melodie pack die
melone in den mülleimer und mich selbst
natürlich auch ich nehme jetzt einfach
mal den müll mit männern
auch wir können wirklich in jeden
haushalt geben wir reingehen und uns
überall umschauen ob irgendwo was ist ob
dabei ist und wir können auch basketball
spielen wenn basketball kommen
das hier ist mein haushalt und ich werde
melanie melone hier drin behalten und
schön waschen und dann ist das hier
meinen ein ganz normales früh stellen
ist ein bisschen kalt gewesen weil ich
sie gerade mit dem wasser da voll
gestellt habe deswegen wird jetzt ein
wenig aufgewärmt hitze gut
melanie melanie hat es in der mikrowelle
leider nicht so gefallen deswegen ist
jetzt im backofen drin und ich haben
herd melanie motto mach doch was diese
geht das jetzt von vorne los und die
musik ist wieder da ich könnte heulen
nicht was soll denn dieser scheiß
dann mach ich schönere musik ich will
mich in dieser nachbarschaft einfach nur
umbringen ich hasse euch alle geht's
einfach weg von billig nehmen
ich will einfach noch schneller
ordensleben fabrik zuschuss nicht mehr
leben meine fresse wie lange es denn
diese blöde treppe terry du warst mir
schon immer ein guter freund aber nicht
behindert wenn du ansprichst wieder
zurück
the following prozesses crashte das hier
ist gerade die fehlermeldung die ich
hier sehe wenn euch das video vielleicht
trotzdem ein bisschen gefallen hat
obwohl es komplett random war und
eigentlich gar keine story beinhaltet
hat dann zeigst bewertet ich hab das
ganze beim viel lieber gesehen und
dachte mir es macht spaß aber hat es
nicht gemacht außerdem sollte der titel
eine anspielung auf den derzeitigen
total kindlichen youtube sein muss wenn
du ein